القمح اساس نظامنا الغذائي بلا منازع تعد
اوكرانيا من اهم الدول المنتجه والمصدره
للقمح حول العالم قبل الحرب كان المزارعون
الاوكرانيون يوفرون للعالم اكثر من خمسه
ملايين طن من القمح شهريا هذه التربه
السوداء الاوكرانيه الشهيره افضل تربه في
العالم هي خصبه للغايه يسمونها تربه الذهب
الاسود اوكرانيا تحوي حوالي 30% منها
وربما نحن الان ننظر الى احد الاسباب
الكامنه وراء الحرب المره الاخيره قصفت
الحقول ومنطقه الحصاد قصفت المنطقه
باكملها
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تطالب نتائجها
وتداعياتها العالم باسره النتيجه الاكثر
ماساويه هي النقص الغذاء وهو هذه المره لا
يميز بين غني وفقير يعتمد الاقتصاد الاوكر
اني على الزراعه ويعيش ما يقرب من ثلث
السكان في المناطق الريفيه
ايا كان من يسيطر على صادرات الحبوب في
العالم فسيملك القوه ثلث صادرات العالم من
القمح ياتي من روسيا واوكرانيا في العام
الماضي سجل حصادنا رقما غير مسبوق في
التاريخ 180 ملايين تم تصدير خمسه وسبعين
في المئه منها في مارس لم نتمكن من تصدير
اكثر من 200 الف طن من المنتجات الزراعيه
قبل الرابع والعشرين من فبراير 2022 تم
الاعلان عن تصدير حوالي خمسه الى سته
ملايين طن تم تدمير حوالي خمسه ملايين طن
بسبب الاعمال العسكريه معظم صادرات القمح
يذهب الى
البناميا غير القادره على انتاج تلك
الحبوب بنفسها وهي البلدان التي تشكل هذه
الحبوب مواد غذائيه ومكونات اساسيه في
اطباقها التقليديه هذه حرب يستخدم فيها
الطعام كسلاح جيوسياسي واجهنا عاصفه قبل
الحرب الاوكرانيه كورونا والمناخ ارتفعت
اعداد منهم على حافه المجاعه من 135
مليونا الى 276
هذا العدد غير مرشح للانخفاض بالنظر لكثره
الاضطرابات المتواصله في سلاسل التوريد
والتي كانت مرتبطه اساسا بالجائحه نواجه
اسوا ازمه غذائيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
سريلانكا
الهند باكستان
ايران لبنان اليمن افريقيا باكملها
الملايين والملايين من الجياع لا بوارد من
اين سته الاموال هل ستطعم الاطفال في
اوكرانيا على حساب الاطفال في اثيوبيا هل
تاخذ طعام الاطفال الافغان الى الاطفال في
اليمن اتطلب مني ان اختار اي من الاطفال
سيعيش واي منهم سيموت الطحين غير متوفر
على الناس ان يبحثوا عنه في السوق السوداء
نتيجه لذلك اسر كثيره ستنام بلا عشاء اما
عاد بامكانها تحمل كل
فه تتدخل الحكومات لمنع ارتفاع اسعار
الخبز وعدم السماح بقيام ما يشبه تلك
الثورات التي ادت قبل اعوام الى ما يعرف
بالربيع العربي
كان البرنامج يشتري الحبوب الاوكرانيه من
اجل اطعام العالم الثالث اليوم ياتي
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي من اجل انقاذ
اوكرانيا وتوزيع المواد الغذائيه على
سكانها
المدنيون يموتون انها ماساه حقيقيه وهي
النتيجه الافضع لهذه الحرب
ميناء اوديستا الذي كان احد اهم الموانئ
البحريه في العالم ظل متوقفا عن العمل
لعده اشهر بعد استهدافه بالقصف الروسي خسر
الاقتصاد الاوكراني سته مليارات دولار
شهريا بسبب حصار الموانئ كانت الصوامع
مليئه بحصاه العام 2021 ولم يكن هناك مكان
لحصاد العام 2022 فماذا كان يفترض
بالمزارعين الاوكرانيين ان يفعلوا الذين
لديهم منشات وقدره ماليه على تخزين حبوبهم
قاموا بذلك اما الاخرون فاخذوا يبيعون
محاصيلهم باسعار زهيده في ظل غياب اي امل
في البذر مره اخرى هل كان من الممكن تصدير
الحبوب من دون استخدام الموانئ على البحر
الاسود في صداقتها النقل بقطارات السكك
الحديديه الى حدودنا الغربيه لكن خط السكه
الحديديه تضرر بشده جراء القصف ثم كانت
هناك مشكله لوجسيه اخرى تعتمد معيارا
لاتساع سكه الحديد مختلفا تماما عن معايير
السكك الحديديه الاوروبيه لذلك كان ينبغي
تفريغ اطنان من الحبوب من عرباتها
وتحميلها على قطارات اخرى ذات عربات
متوافقه مع المسارات الاوروبيه مساله
ضعيفه الجدوى من الناحيه العمليه
في اسطنبول في 22 من يوليو 2022 فاستعاد
السفن الشحن نشاطها لتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه يجب الاعتراف بان الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قد لعب دورا لم
يلعب الاخرون اي حل نتوصل اليه كافيا فمنذ
فجر البشريه كانت الحرب اكبر مسبب للجوع
كتلك التي تدور راحها الان في اوكر انيا